تمر
[تصفيق]
كيف تتحول تسديده كره الى قذيفه صاروخيه
تحمل ثارا سياسيا او تغدو ارنب يجري هربا
من الصياد هل ثبت رابط بين هرمون الذكوره
ومشاهده مباريات كره القدم الى اي مدى
تؤثر هذه المستديره في نفوس عشاقها ولماذا
تدفعهم الى الخروج عن السيطره احيانا
وتتسبب في صدمات داميه ومعارك الشرسه
ان كنت تعتقد انها ليست سوى لعبه يلتف
حولها الملايين من المشجعين الفضوليين فقط
تكون مخطئا في تقديرك
سنخبرك كيف
[تصفيق]
قبل ان يفارق الحياه على 2015 باع مجره
للحاق بمنتخب بلاده وتشجيعه تنقل بين 60
دوله في العالم وكان حاضرا في جميع النسخ
كاس العالم منذ عام
1994 حتى عام 2014 قال ذات يوم اعتبر نفسي
اللاعب رقم 12 انا اشجع واهاتف وانا
اللاعب صاحب اكبر عدد من المباريات
الدوليه فما الذي يعزز هذا الانقباط لدى
المشجع
تظهير الدراسات العلميه ارتفاع افرازات
بعض الهرمونات لدى الرياضيين نتيجه
التحفيز والجهد المبذول خلال المباريات
لكن الصادمه كان في دراسه اجرها عالم
السلوك
اثبتت مرور المشجعين بحاله لا تختلف كثيرا
عن اللاعبين في المباراه تمثلت في ارتفاع
افرازات هرمون التستوستيرون او ما يعرف
بهرمون الذكوره الرئيسيه لدى المشجعين
وبمستويات الاعلى بنسبه 20 بالمئه لدى
جماهير الفريق الفائز نتائج مشابهه لحظات
ايضا في هرمونات اخرى
مدى التحفيز والارتباط العميق الذي يعيشه
المشجع خلال المشتريات المباراه التي
يلعبها فريقه
محمد صلاح جول ام لا صلاح
[تصفيق]
هذا الارتباط الطاقوده مجموعه معينه من
الخلايا العصبيه تدعى المراهيه التي تعمل
كرادار يرصد الانشطه المحيطه ويخلق شعورا
مشابها لها في النفس البشريه فيبدو المشجع
مندمجا بصوره تكاد تطابق دماجا اللاعب في
المباراه
[تصفيق]
هذه المعادله تتخطى العلاقه بين المشجع
واللاعب وتنتقل بين المشاهدين على حد سواء
ان كنت من غير المتابعين لكره القدم فقد
تجد نفسك مرغما على مشاهده مباراه برفقه
الاصدقاء المشجعين وسرعان ما تصبح متفاعلا
مع فريقا ربما لم تسمع به من قبل نتيجه
تاثرك بتفاعل الاصدقاء من حولك دون وعد
عرف الانسان القديم
منذ الاف سنين كوسيله للبقاء يجري خلف
طريته املا في الحصول على ما يسد رمقه
ويجد المتعه في ذلك حتى لم تكل الجهوده
بالنجاح هذه الغريزه انتقلت مع الانسان
على مر العصور وبقيت سمه ملازمه للسلوك
البشري الامر الذي دفع عالم الحيوان دازما
مورس الى ربط معظم اشكال الرياضه التي
نعرفها اليوم بالصيد وعدها بديلا عن تلك
الغريزه التي انقرضت في صورتها التقليديه
ما تطور الحضارات وتبدل سوريا
حتى اصبحت هذه الكره اليوم اشبه ما تكون
بالفريسه يجري خلفها مجموعه من الصيادين
المحترفين
ويشجعوهم على ذلك افواج من المشاهدين
المتعطشين لاصطياد الفريسه ووضعها في
الشباك
يمكن فهمه هذا تصور اكثر بالعوده الى
العصر الروماني عندما كانت تقام مباريات
البقاء بين الوحوش المفترسه مثل الاسود
ومجرمين محكومين عليهم بالموت عروض لا
تختلف كثيرا عن نهائي كاس العالم اليوم
حيث يحتسد عشرات الالاف لمشاهده الصراع
الفريسه والصياد
ربما سمعت مشجعا فرحا بعد المباراه يصرخ
انتصرنا
[تصفيق]
هكذا بصيغه الجمع ذلك ان المشجع يرى رابطا
نفسيا يجمعه بفريقه اقرب ما يكون الى
الرابطه القبليه واذا كان الانسان القديم
مستمد فخره وامجاده من الحروب والغزوات
التي يخوضها برفقه قبيلته تشير مديره
المختبر العلوم العصبيه في جامعه
الرياضيه قد تكون الشكل الحديث من الحروب
القبليه التي يستمد منها الفرد شعوره
بالنصر والفخر بعيدا عن الدماء والقتل
جانب يلخصه عالم النفس
بقوله ان الرياضيين هم جيشنا المحارب
ويؤكده الزعيم الايطاليه
الذي راى في الرياضه عاملا لتوحيد الشعبي
وتعزيز نازعته القوميه
هذا الكم الهائل من الاحاسيس المختلطه
التي تقوم بمشجع الى هذا الارتباط العميق
بالمدرجات لم تخلوا في بعض الاحيان من
دوافع اكبر بكثير من دعم مجموعه من
اللاعبين يتقاضفون كره في ما بينهم
لتتحول هذه المدرجات الى ما يشبه المنابر
السياسيه
وياخذ المستطيل الاخضر ساحه لتصفيه حسابات
لم تغلق في ميدان البندق
مشهد يتجلى في اشرس صوره في المنافسه
الاشهر الكلاسيكو برشلونه الذي يمثل
الاقليم الكتلونيه الحالم بالاستقلال عن
الحكومه المركزيه الاسبانيه في مواجهه
النادي الملكي ريال مدريد
[موسيقى]
يرى سكان الاقليم في ناديهم وسيله لابرازي
هويتهم التي سحقت خلال عهد الجنرال فرانكو
الدعم الاول للنادي الملكي والذي قصف ملعب
الكامب نو نو عام
واذاق كتالونيا الولايات وذلك ما يفسر
حماسه مشجعين ناديين خلال اللقاءات
المتكرره
فالمشجع الكتلوني يرى تسديده لاعبين به
اضيفه صاروخيه تمثل الفقرا لم يحسم خارج
اسوار الملاعب في حين يرغو مدريد ان الفوز
على الكتلان
يؤكد صفوه الحكم الملكي على الاقليم
ذاكره الملاعب مليئه بالحوادث الماساويه
الناتجه عن خروج المشجعين عن السيطره
327 قتيلا في بيروت على
44 قتيلا في تركيا عام
130 قتيلا في دانه عام 2001
125 قتيلا في اندونيسيا عام 2022
وغيرها الكثير وفي حين يوجه الشكر الى
المدرجات لدورها في اطفاء جوي من المتعه
والاثاره على اللعبه يتخطل بعض حدودا
حمراء وتبدا الامور تتحول من التشجيع الى
الجنود لتاخذ منعطف خطرا يقلب المتعه الى
ماساه تصبغ الملاعب باللون الاحمر بعد
كلها هذا عنك
هل انت من المهووسين بكره القدم وهل تستحق
هذه الكره الصغيره كل هذا الهوى حقا